you talk about what you think are the
major contributing factors to cancer can
you talk a little bit about some of the
components of that that maybe not aren't
so obvious to people that involve this
buried emotional trauma that you spend a
lot of time on
i think the biggest drivers to cancer
are environmental toxins which we spoke
about
uh disconnect from nature
and uh emotional suppression i think
those
are bigger drivers to cancer
than i know actually uh than genetics
then lack of exercise
than unhealthy diet i think those are
bigger pieces of the pie so what does
that mean like emotional like is it is
it trauma you've experienced in your
life that you haven't dealt with
properly
what does that look like what does it do
to the body and what is the best way to
fix that because i know a lot of people
say i go to therapy it doesn't help i
there's a you know obviously big pharma
wants to just throw drugs at you all the
time so what do you do here
you get back to yourself so most people
walking around that you see
are
suppressing emotion most of us
doesn't have to be trauma we don't have
to have had molestation or rape or
anything very serious in our lives to
have trauma stuck in our body
the way that it works is this
we
are all children and we are all
self-expressed as children generally you
have children i'm sure your child is
happy when it's happy sad when it's sad
yeah angry when he or she is angry yes
and and you see it and we appreciate it
as parents and actually as adults we're
attracted to that why because at some
point that was us
and at some point that was lost
the question is why was it lost
oftentimes it manifests this way
when we are expressing ourselves as
children
we are told that at some point we can't
or we shouldn't or this is not
acceptable and in those moments i call
that actually original sin is in those
moments we contract
and we create this mechanism that
protects us from ever expressing that
emotion again right so let's work with
anger most people
are familiar with anger a lot of us can
express anger but most of us can't
especially in today's society and
certainly don't have those outlets so
when we're young and let's say for
example i'm in school and i'm angry
because you know
ralph took my car and he's not giving it
back and the teacher's saying that he
never took my car and i feel injustice
and i feel angry
and i'm told calm down this is not how
we do it this is not you're you're a big
boy now you're not supposed to be like
this
my mechanism starts developing right and
this is a really important thing because
if you really truly listen to this part
a lot of parents out there will notice
when anger starts coming up again in
school or even at home
that mechanism starts to show up now for
me it can show up as humor so say for
example when i start feeling angry or
when i start feeling that real emotion
that's not acceptable by society
that humor starts showing up so all of a
sudden i start being a really funny kid
when i'm uncomfortable right and i know
a lot of us can relate to it because we
know a lot of people who are
inappropriately funny in moments that
they shouldn't be
and that's the phenomenon where and we
developed this because as children
we are the most
egocentric in the most beautiful ways
right if mom's mad it's probably because
of us that's what we believe if dad's
mad it's probably because of us because
we can't rationalize or cognize that
maybe they had a hard day at work or
maybe there's financial troubles or
maybe they had a they have issues with
their parents or something we don't
think about that we go to us right so in
that self-centered
understanding of the world we make the
adjustment thinking that we will make
teacher mom dad whoever it is happy by
knowing that if i'm humorous because i
know that dad responds to humor mom
responds to humor when my teacher
responds to humor then i'll protect
myself the problem is this
we blend with that protective mechanism
for the rest of our lives we start to
believe that it's part of us we actually
start to integrate it in our persona
which is not us our personality is not
us it's only a part of us right and then
we begin to believe that we are
humorous we i am a funny guy i'm a
comedian right and yeah we might have
that talent for it but all of a sudden
when there's real emotions in
relationships or in in business or
something that really needs to be
expressed that humor comes up and
protects us and we don't know how to get
past it
that's emotional suppression
that anger that wants to come up but
keeps getting blocked by that protective
mechanism i.e humor in this example
is not going it's not able to be
expressed this is why
you see people
let's say for example have meltdowns
right there's a flat tire and they're
freaking out and you're like whoa dude
it's just a flat tire what's going on
that's me
yeah that's because
that the the charge and the energy of
that experience
surpasses that compensative mechanism to
start being expressed in the body
finally in a way that has been been
suppressed for so many years we're so
scared to show emotion society has put
us in a place where we're not allowed to
show emotion i feel a lot for women
women especially can't express their
anger in society right and i feel a lot
for men because men can't really show
their sadness or tears in society
and and in my work i've seen so much of
it women have lost their power in their
anger because anger and power are tied
together especially in the same part of
the body and men have lost so much of
their sadness
and when i see it in front of me finally
a human being coming back into contact
with the parts of them that they've been
suppressing since childhood
that is the most spontaneous healing
i've ever seen ever if you like the
short clip you can catch another one
here or you can catch the full episode
right here
you